hello everyone we are in Austin Texas
for Fantastic Fest and we are super
excited to have mr. Takashi Miike I hope
I said it correctly legendary director
promoting his movie first love and his
interpreter as well David correct yes
thank you for being here and having us
talk to you we I got to see this movie
yesterday I loved it I was so happy with
it it was like I'm telling people it's
my favorite romantic comedy of the year
so I wanted to congratulate you on your
lifetime achievement award that you got
yesterday and asked about you know you
you've been making like 90 movies in 30
years which is insane and they're all
full of hilarity and violins and the
human condition so how you come up with
all of these ideas and for every single
movie that keep us you know shocking and
that are so shocking and that keep us
laughing etc so say no talk about show
more Suzanne oh geez oh sorry Naruto
master c'mon yeah how do you know
sunjoon in Kannada I know he provoked
you you home ego no you don't know
successor Tanaka day oh no sue them oh I
know Mike I'm a guy I know borio cool
and I know more virus into Carnegie and
Sega recorded oh yeah could take down
there no yeah there are no more Omashu
Romano buckets no such way a shitzu
chemist ahsoka soon a demo conquer yet
Bacardi Janek tell her yet need yacyretá
Cano animo gumpa array me familiarity
awesome oh I don't know they say he has
a coup d'etat machined my Roboto
well absolutely and thank you and yes
that's very true but this this film is a
little bit different because instead of
just having a whole bunch of bad guys
the whole time we also have you know a
little doggie that gets bullied by these
you know these big bad Yakuza guys and
who is who also shows this his struggle
with in this film it's so it's more of
like a family film than most of my other
films that's right you did he did
mention in the Q&A yesterday that these
are movies that hopefully entertain the
kids like Pokemon movies so this unit
emoji sign-on and ever
so no cheesy no tuna and you could see
not demo kodomo no toki no kokoro ten no
hotels you know who donkeys can I
ducky there sorry oh oh no materials you
can no no koto mo ticky not so no purana
kokoro tori models do you sugar
horrible no no mikata absolutely and I
think not just of kids but of course
adults that still have a kid dormant and
they want to bring back that you know
their their their their kid heart I
think this is actually a good film
for that as well so you know she
mentioned obviously just incredible
lifetime there's filmmaking achievements
and yeah it's sort of a resume that most
people could only dream of and when you
have that many films that you've made
what what excites you as a storyteller
now how do you how do you know that this
is a something an idea you've had that
needs to be made into a film when you
sort of hit every genre there is to hit
already yeah
no sure no I know Kazoku no super a CEO
I know caseinate it's what I take that
too you know but talk about Socorro so
that one not anymore
yeah is for the more I know the more I
know my mother so this name another Mito
Google kanji data to a halt it's good
that it certainly must see I know I'm
sorry what was the question again what
really strikes you in a story when
you've made so many films that you got I
have to make this movie it's really more
oh no Joe you're gonna it's great item
or do you are a mustache oka hmm look
let's talk about the core oh show to you
soon and come oh yeah what's kratom at
the move what
Oh ji Chang camera - can end a memo
ojii-chan to worry to me grainy not it
sidewalk attack you know II today - oh
oh oh my Karaka of mother mother
Gambrinus io ahjumma topic reader do you
start when you Maura viola
so it's Marie de mono dakara nonde Hana
veteran not de Bannon inaccurate Osaka
he know Arabic de voto are communicate
oh gee bonito Tanaka strategy cocoon a
load a psycho acoustic guitar yamaha
negro madamada atarashi started toboggan
and a marijuana aurora takaku tu through
a budget of Aragon Ikaruga rubble
studied Arabic oh that are alga and
abiotic tight
so about the lifetime achievement part
you know I feel like that's really that
kind of that award is something that you
would give to a grandpa when he's like
you know he's done with this whole
career you're like okay well done
congratulations here you go
and for me and you know and I definitely
i'm not particularly young so you know
but I feel like I'm still going I feel
like this is still you know for me this
is kind of encouragement for me to keep
going and I feel like this is kind of a
motivation for me to make a fresh start
you know and you know maybe a veteran
filmmaker would take this to say okay
well this is it I'm done but for me it's
like I want to take the time that I have
left and I want to really you know just
take all the projects that come my way
you know the Yakuza films the love films
and all the other crazy films that come
my way and you know just really give my
all to those so where do you think that
that deep of a love for cinema comes
from that you you want to spend the rest
of your life making movies I know I know
Geno's I'll go mad a he-goat school it's
a good I to you oh no omoi wa doko kara
a cluster shoka no joke on took me had
you met a more eager Loompa new hajimeta
that tomorrow to a Thundercat all done
done so much you go to antique market a
who don't what Taku nama came on all day
to see relativity oh yeah couldn't at a
nine inning game under Godot yellow game
bow Tony Saturday game when you a joke
on talk to you touchable there Nara na
Rica who da na jibun de jouvenel
the regimen to take a go no game
hanahuna dismal ticket to are totally
running in the moment
yeah so you even know German
oh good and ontology on query katabatic
Hebrew basher the SATs a game on and
it's even yet she owned a personal you
know for me you know even when I was a
an assistant director you know the you
know set and you know location where we
were filming was just a place that you
know where I could actually maybe be a
different version of myself
I'm normally kind of a lazy person and I
kind of feel like I'm useless you know
in many regards but when I'm you know on
location around on set filming you know
I really am able to be kind of a
different me and and I feel like if I
was not if I'm not on a film set I kind
of feel like I'm useless or kind of like
I'm a worthless person so that's the
place where I really feel like I'm most
at home and I really can be maybe the
best version of myself or a different
version of myself and and and I and I
can I plan to continue doing that so and
bringing that theme
you know those themes in this and all
your movies if ever since I saw audition
you know including this movie in first
love I feel like all the characters are
trying to survive as well as figure out
why they're here right why what keep
what is keeping them alive is that
something that that's something that I
noticed in all your movies and sorry I'm
getting too philosophical here David but
so so I'm wondering it is that kind of
what you're hoping to you know share
with audiences through your films that
we're all kind of struggling to do that
right and surviving everyday and it
seems like Leo the boxer in this movie
in first love was doing that as well as
the the people in the Yakuza and some of
them were idiots in the movie and they
were funny but they were still also
trying to survive
oh this you know G that cut up my comb
cannot see no mother I know it's know
kinda cherry tomatoes tois Suez name I
know he pretty Aquino kuru kuru I know
Tommy non-combat in a garage
yeah Brianna Akira Iggy oh uh no
Sadhguru do you tame Agha
Oh Angela Scott okuni come kawasu the
steno keyboard on Cano what do Cara I
know meets Karen Oh God hey MA Akira do
Curatola toka mo unencumbered negara he
took kuhnian oh ma do more so that I see
Yakuza no no Kazuma so dependence is
more preferable it was rock on top son
la mina sunny no huge tada Thiru ito
message ii desuka you will know Agana
a deepening game chant estate
stenographer ethical 90 min de que tenga
son okay Kazoku go to stay up there
Naruto cos Yakuza no naka de mo
dominated a demo John Watson Union
character his own ningún Rizzo
conservators Negara conquer
non-scientists Eva
Don Muraco Darin Itoko ningún no casa da
da da una mirada trainingand mo y eso
kinesins I stated yo nani Cano keyboa no
cosmo no Sugino Jade I need my career
away
you know geochemical Terranea Resort
aquí desde una y no se toca any target
the auto Monica no is created me no saki
Hinda do you need to write I think we
see where
you know this film for me is a film
where I feel like you know we all have
you know all of these defects and we
have you know the yaku's I have defects
as well you know we have some pretty
rough-and-tumble characters there and
yet we identify with those we see those
characters and we and we see them you
know they're they're not great people
but we see their humanity and we end up
you know loving them and so they could
be you know human garbage but yet you
know and they're you know obviously you
know there's obviously a lot of you know
a lot of rough stuff going on there but
yet there's hope that exists and in this
specific case you know you have these
two characters that meet you know with
that you know with against the in that
context and they end up having you know
kind of a love relationship you know Leo
and Monica and so I think you know no
matter how terrible things are and no
matter you know how rough life is you
know there's always something you can
find out of that that's redeemable so
baby Chihuahua and I immediately have to
bind which which makes me think of you
know one of my favorite scenes in the
film and something that I loved in all
of your films is imagery that to me
immediately burns in your brain and
stays there forever and I'm curious what
are the images that inspire you when
you're out in the world what do you see
that really sticks in your mind did Oh
No
Mika canto googa Amano - I know I know I
know you put it moot the musky the more
I couldn't meet their mother semester
yeah how do you know Mika canto a egga
know each one's kina to crowbar through
this name more I know meet their I know
some image on me tear and also as nano
hominid I know zoo - nakuru you wanna
imagine a witness named Jay no Mickey
can turn into a ya parent admire you no
naka de don't do you imagine me tell ya
piano zuto anno domini on Nakuru
Nacirema no re masazuka
talkin it
soldiers some money
nanika egg on oprah's initio to carve
the you go to death
you know the committed of occasionally
to come up Sunni Conger koto the
terrible evil meet em all Jeevan wah you
know Entertainment Caracas tetanus you
today to your king of inert of a Nibiru
nominee Allah Mira Shivan dragon son
constitute about you cotton sense in
night so you in nan de la Dupre attach
it to our initial taking the monogatari
Calcutta targets could technically die
hunger so you who nominal script you die
only continuo this was torture scene
indicate Oh tada
epic era no character Skeeter's mano in
England ng table
Raksha training and touch tuition its
greatest equality so you cannot you
cannot Salinas you know I actually don't
you know I the way that I you know kind
of consumed film and you know and
observe the world the way that I see it
you know I really don't I like to sit
back and kind of just enjoy film as
entertainment
you know while I'm drinking a beer and
so I'm not really using that as a
reference you know to incorporate into
my own film so I don't really have
images that are burned in my mind in
that way but what I do have is maybe
characters you know that I focus on and
you know like in the script you have
these characters and this dog is
actually not one of those characters you
know this dog you know was kind of
created and added you know in
conjunction with the characters and the
human actors and you know you know it
just kind of came up is you know
incidentally as part of our filming but
that's kind of the way you know that's
kind of the way that I see the
I don't try to you know see what I
imagery I can find and try to add that
to my films that's just not the way that
I that I work as a person so I also say
I think I'm saying it properly but it's
what does she want
I think it's that's how do you say I
love you I want this run on me thank you
so much everyone check out first love
it's an amazing movie thank you again
thank you thank you so much he's fun